[Music]
are you gonna play Mass Effect Andromeda
on PC then boy do I have some news for
you EA has revealed the minimum and
recommended specs for the spacefaring
RPG and we've got them for you right
here I'm Matt this is a game spot news
update and make sure to like them
subscribe so you'll be the first to see
all of our upcoming Mass Effect coverage
the minimum specs aren't particularly
demanding only calling for a 2 gigabyte
gtx 660 or Radeon 7850 to be paired with
a kikah bytes of ram and an i5 3570k and
needs at least the GTX 1060 or our X 480
with 16 gigabytes of ram and an i 747 90
or FX 8350 unfortunately EA didn't
specify what level of quality frame rate
or resolution these specs are for which
is what Ubisoft has done with its past
couple of games Mass Effect Andromeda
releases for ps4 xbox one and pc on
March 21st a multiplayer beta is
expected to launch at some point before
then which may give you the opportunity
to test it out and see how it runs on
your system we'll keep you updated on
when that beta goes live but for now
check out our preview of Andromeda which
lets us conflicted and worried about the
full game